à Félix Auger-Aliassime!
- Félix Auger-Aliassime
a rendez-vous avec Holger Rune,
en finale du tournoi de Bâle,
de la saison.
Le Québécois ne perd pas
de temps avant de prendre
le matchle jeune Danois de 19 as
le quatrième jeu, un mince jeu
d'avance qui suffit au Québécois
pour remporter la première
engagement est plus disputé.
Les deux hommes bataillent ferme
au service. Le défi est
maintenant de savoir qui
et ce sera le jeune Danois,
alors au service à 5-5.
Auger-Aliassime remporte le jeu
suivant et remporte sa quatr
victoire de la saison.
Il termine le tournoi
au service et compte désormais
13 gains d'affiléeence
impressionnante qui ajoute
à cette fin de saison
rendent le moment encore
plus incroyable.
Ce troisième titre consécutif,
après ceux obtenproche un peu
plus le neuvième joueur mondial
d'une place en finale de l'ATP,
à la mi-novembre, à Turin.
Au même moment,ov a vendu chèrt
sa peau en finale du tournoi
face à la quatrième raquette
mondialemondialemondialemondiall
Medvedev. Le Canadien de 23 ans
a bien entamé la rencontrea pree
manche. Medvedev s'est cependané
les deux manches suivantes pour
célébrer son deuxiois manches
de 4-6, 6-3, 6-2.
pour Shapovalov, qui montre les
dents en cette fin de saison
Shapovalov et Auger-Aliassime
devront vite se remettre
Ils seront de retour en action
dans quelques heures à pei
au dernier Masters de la saison,
à Paris.
Olivier Pellerin,
Radio-Canada, Mon